If I ask you to think of
a country where more than 80% of
the inhabitants live in state-built homes,
many will surely think of a socialist republic
or maybe a former Soviet bloc country, right?
But...
What if I told you that this figure corresponds
to one of the countries with the freest and
most deregulated economies?
Possibly the most capitalist country in the
world.
Surprised?
Well, Singapore is an unusual case, an exception
in terms of housing models.
This Southeast asian city-state, famous for
its towering skyscrapers, impossible architecture
and for being one of the largest financial
centers in the world, has developed a public
housing system that is globally unique.
Some of you may be thinking, but Simon, you
already told us, on this very channel, that
Vienna also has an extensive public housing
system!
Well yes, you're right.
However, we’re talking about two very different
models.
Completely different.
The great difference between Vienna and Singapore’s
model lies particularly in the percentage
of property owners.
While the Viennese model is oriented towards
rentals, three-quarters of the population
rents city council-owned homes, the Singapore
model is just the opposite.
More than 90% of Singapore’s citizens own
their own homes.
Of course, 80% own homes promoted, built and
granted by the state.
Yes, we’re talking ownership-oriented public
housing.
Ownership with a few catches, if we’re being
completely honest.
But...
We'll talk about that later.
First, we need to ask ourselves some questions:
Why does Singapore apparently reject the free
market real-estate model?
How on earth can they develop a property-oriented
public housing system?
How has this model affected private real estate
developments?
And...Is the Singapore model replicable in
other countries?
Well, let's get to the bottom of all these
questions.
Listen up.
(SINGAPORE, LITTLE LAND AND A HUGE POPULATION)
Dear friends of VisualPolitik.
First, we need to familiarise ourselves with
the context.
Check out this map.
(MAP)
Singapore is a city-state with just over 700
km2 but with more than five and a half million
inhabitants.
This has forced more than 70% of the land
to be built on.
Those are the red areas of the map.
The remaining 30% includes mostly protected
areas or land where one simply can’t build.
Basically, the city is overflowing.
Faced with such a scenario, it wouldn’t
be unreasonable to think that accessing a
home in Singapore would be a headache, would
it?
After all, that’s the case in similar places
such as Hong Kong.
Well, strangely enough...
It isn’t.
The reason has a lot to do with Singapore’s
unique urban development model.
Check this out, in 1960 the Singapore government
created the Housing and Development Board,
a public housing company that’s responsible
for regulating and managing the land, as well
as building and developing real estate projects.
And that’s because since 1967, most of the
land in Singapore has been publicly owned.
In that year, 1967, the so-called Land Acquisition
Act was approved, which enabled the government
to take back ownership of all the land.
That means, the land marketed for real estate
development is made available under the Housing
Board’s criteria.
That is, there isn’t a price system in land
commercialization.
Let me explain it in another way.
This public body determines how many homes
it will build; and at what prices and under
what conditions they will be marketed – evidently
always below the potential market price.
On the other hand, it’s this same organization,
this Housing and Development Board, which
draws land for auction so private developers
can build completely private real estate projects.
Of course, in every case, the land continues
to be publicly owned, that is, the homeowners
cannot do whatever they want with it – for
example they can’t sell their homes to build
a hotel.
And the property is more a concession than
a property.
Allow me to explain myself.
When a citizen of Singapore – and I emphasize
this because foreigners can’t buy new public
housing – gets one of these homes, they
aren’t really acquiring the land’s ownership
nor the house itself, but only the right to
stay in it, a kind of lease that lasts for
99 years.
After that period, the house returns to the
state.
This is how the Prime Minister of Singapore
explains it:
(AUDIO: “After 99 years, the flat comes
back to the state, the Government redevelops
the land, and builds new flats for future
generations.
This is the only way to recycle the land,
to ensure all our descendants can buy new
flats of their own.
If instead the Government sold you the flat
on freehold … Sooner or later we would run
out of land to build new flats.”
Lee Hsien Loong, Prime Minister of Singapore.)
And, you have to be careful, because in private
developments this period may be even shorter.
Of course, during the lease period “the
owners” can do whatever they deem appropriate
with the house.
If they don't want to live in it, they can
sell it or rent it.
In fact, it isn’t uncommon, if things are
going well, for those who own older homes
to sell or rent the “public” homes, which
tend to be very austere – especially the
old ones – in order to move into private
developments, which in Singapore’s case
are far more luxurious.
But the peculiarities of this curious system
don’t end there.
Since the body that builds and sells most
homes is public, the government uses it as
a social policy instrument.
Or rather, an instrument of social engineering.
For example, to avoid the formation of ghettos
given that Singapore’s population has a
certain racial diversity, a building or development’s
dwellings are allocated in such a way that
the proportion of owners has an ethnic distribution
that reflects the distribution in the whole
country.
The population distribution by ethnic group
in Singapore looks something like this:
In each block of homes the owners are distributed
more or less in the same way.
If a block or a project has, for example,
100 homes, then we’ll find 74 Chinese owners,
13 Malaysian owners, 9 Indian owners, and
so on.
However, that’s not a bad thing.
Perhaps the worst aspect of this model is
that the government uses the granting of homes
to promote certain life models.
For example, traditional couples don’t have
any problems applying for a government property,
but single people or same-sex couples…
Well, let's just say it’s much more complicated
for them.
Surprised?
Isn’t it strange to find such interventionism
in a supposedly capitalist place?
Well, it shouldn’t be surprising, we already
told you that Singapore’s political, economic
and social model is a kind of mix between
free-market capitalist policies and very,
very paternalistic policies where the state
actively promotes certain ways of life and
punishes others.
In this case, in the area of housing, not
only in housing allocation, but also, for
example, mortgage approvals, conditions are
very advantageous for people who meet the
state-imposed criteria.
If you don't, well... bad luck.
Do you want to live alone?
Sorry.
Do you want to live with a friend?
Too bad.
Do you want to live with your same-sex partner?
Well... you know... we wish we could help
but...
Now, beyond these rather questionable practices,
the truth is that this system has been quite
successful.
Public housing is much more affordable in
Singapore than in other cities with comparable
economic success, such as London, Sydney or
Hong Kong.
On average, new buyers spend less than a quarter
of their income on their mortgage.
But... just a second.
All this isn’t free.
(THE ECONOMIC INVOICE DILEMMA)
If the government of Singapore is known for
one thing, it’s for keeping taxes and public
spending at bay.
However, things are different with this whole
housing issue.
The system is clearly lacking:
(AUDIO: HDB reports $1.47 billion loss in
latest financial year as fewer flats sold
- Channel New Asia)
1.5 billion dollars, that’s the difference
between what urbanization and construction
work costs the state and the income it receives
from selling the homes.
That’s 1.5 billion dollars that is financed
from the public budget.
The whole housing scheme is basically financed
with taxes.
Regardless of land ownership, this is the
annual allocation that the Singapore government
devotes to its housing policy.
A perfectly acceptable amount for an economy
as big as Singapore’s.
Now, does this mean that the governments of
other countries should take back ownership
of city lands and oversee housing development,
just like the Singapore government does?
Not at all.
Singapore’s case is very particular.
We’re talking about a city-state with huge
economic success, a state which is managed
almost like a company and where land limitations
are more than evident.
The differences with other countries are quite
obvious.
Nor is it clear that if it was operating as
a free market – a truly free one – the
results would be much different.
Not to mention the enormous power that such
systems grant politicians to design societies
at will.
But what Singapore has really achieved with
this model – and I think it’s undeniable
– has been to develop an urban planning
and real estate price scheme that favors the
development of many other activities with
greater added value.
For example, given that housing prices are
capped, Singaporean citizens have a greater
capacity to save and invest in, for example,
new businesses.
Anyway, this is Singapore’s unique model,
yet another model up for debate.
So, now it’s your turn.
What do you think of the Singaporean housing
model?
Leave your answer in the comments.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.